[Musique]
de retour avec une conclusion un peu
spéciale à cette émission parce que vous
regardez présentement notre 3 100e
épisode d' enquête 13 saisons de
reportages qui vous ont souvent indignes
et parfois beaucoup touché et ce soir on
veut rendre hommage à toutes ces
personnes qui nous ont permis au fil des
ans de vous faire ces révélations alors
pour marquer le coup je vous amène à nos
bureaux
c'est ici bienvenue dans nos vrais
bureaux gardés pas trop le ménage parce
qu'on déménage bientôt mais c'est ici
depuis 13 saisons kung fu et qu'on
gratte aux histoires des gros dossiers à
penser à toutes nos histoires sur snc
lavalin puis anne dans nos rencontres et
du monde pour faire tous ces grands
reportages
je dirais des dizaines marie monde parce
qu'on a quand même fait cinq reportages
espérant sur snc-lavalin alors on
rencontré des gens au canada mais aussi
en algérie en tunisie en libye et en
libye ya des gens qui nous ont parlé le
moment où au péril de leur vie
sadi pouvait demander 5 ou 6000 $ à la
réception de l'hôtel et snc lavalin
passé derrière et remboursait riadh ben
aïssa payer pour toutes les dépenses de
sadi les chambres d'hôtel ses frasques
comme le soir où il a pratiquement mis
le feu aux rideaux lors d'une fête
snc lavalin assumer absolument tout je
pense à cette personne qui avait
tellement peur des représailles qu'elles
m'avaient donné rendez vous sur un banc
public mais dans un parc à peu près deux
heures de route de montréal
ces rencontres clandestines ont été très
payante pour l'intérêt public et je
pense à d'autres gens aussi qui ont pris
des risques pour nous permettre de
révéler des histoires je pense à ken
pereira par exemple qui est devenu un
paria la ftq construction après les
révélations qui nous a fait j'ai des
soldes on va voir mon cochon tu donc ça
joue pas mal dur ajouté les scores dans
la construction
est ce que vous vous avez peur de parler
son adresse est vite lol je parlerai pas
c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
c'est sûr qu'elle pourquoi parce que
c'est trop dangereux
c'est par une compagnie
dans plusieurs cas la condition pour
nous accorder une entrevue et de ne pas
être identifié nos équipes techniques
ont dû trouver toutes sortes d'astuces
leur participation bien que derrière un
écran a certainement contribué à nous
permettre de révéler de grands histoire
parfois le contexte change et certaines
sources confidentielles décide de sortir
de l'ombre
certains ont changé drôle d'abord du
mauvais côté de l'histoire dans l'
enquête sur boisbriand lino zambito est
ensuite devenu une de nos sources à la
caméra et plus tard un témoin clé de la
commission charbonneau
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous savez sur ce qu'il a
fait pendant son absence briller ça
c'est comme une page qui a tourné de sa
vie il veut pas en parler du tout jamais
non pas du tout chantant des foyers des
gens qui communiquent avec nous pour
qu'on éclaircisse un mystère qui les
arrange personnellement oui une personne
qui ne soit contacté comme ça parce que
ses proches étaient soupçonnés d'être
mêlés avec john montréal et à une
histoire de prises d'otages en syrie et
tout en redoutant un + la réponse est
personne n'en voulait qu'on l'aide à
savoir et on se fait confiance et c'est
certain sens c'est personnel jamais on
n'aurait pu établir jusqu'à quel point
des jeunes d'ici étaient mêlés à cette
grosse histoire internationale
en réponse l'autre membre de notre
équipe qui m brasse et des grosses
affaires internationales ces frais de
l'exo là qu il nous représente au sein
du consortium international des
journalistes d' enquête et nous donne
parfois de la formation on pense par
exemple sur ce qui a obtenu ni panama
papers a décidé de contacter le
consortium des journalistes parce que
c'était tellement d'informations sur
tellement de pays à travers le monde que
c'est impossible pour un média pour un
journaliste de fouiller tout ça q des
ministres qui ont démissionné des
premiers ministres qui ont démissionné
aussi et ça me cette question-là des
paradis fiscaux vraiment sur le radar
internationale et les scandales sont les
paradis fiscaux à l'international ça ne
nous empêche pas de nous intéresser à la
chasse aux orignaux de façon hyper local
luc tu en es it loud en gaspésie oui bah
écoute tu sais qu'en forêt à la chasse
il ya beaucoup d'intimidations entre les
chasseurs les chasseurs sur toi de rien
sont très territoriaux regardez il n'y a
pas de regarder une rolls on est vrai
j'apprends des chargeuses à retourner le
concrètement qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
déjà sur le terrain pour t'aider je
savais qu'il avait beaucoup de chasseurs
qui aimait pas l'intimidation faudrait
donc j'en ai rencontré de plusieurs
certes on accepter qu'on finance et
demande de me dire où ça se passe et où
ça brasse en forêt y en a même qui sont
venus avec nous pour nous montrer où
placer des caméras cachées et c'est
comme ça qu'on a pu réussir cette
enquête qui à l'époque avait beaucoup
marqué les hawks avaient été assez
marquant vous l'aurez compris ce dont on
a besoin ce sont des documents l'épreuve
des enregistrements même et iode nos
collaborateurs qui nous aident à lui
procurer ses preuves le est justement
pascal alors la famille pas d'hier était
vraiment importante pour nous dans le
reportage qu'on a fait sur sainte
justine qui avait fait une étude
clinique qui a été fermé d'urgence par
santé canada
on le savait que la fille de la famille
va dès lors leur plus jeune était
décédée alors qu'elle recevait des
traitements
parce qu'on savait pas c'est qu'est ce
que le médecin avait promis aux familles
lorsqu'il les avait rencontrés pour les
convaincre de participer à cette étude
l'homme
quand on aura compris la famille badea
ils nous ont dit on l'a enregistré
neuf fois durant l'entretien le
chercheur prononcera le mot rémission
pour new star j'y serai là c'était
presque un smoking gun sa démontré que
le médecin avait créé de faux espoirs en
promettant des rémissions dans une étude
comme celle là c'était presque
impossible
quand vous avez dit à pascal on à
l'enregistrement
avez vous hésité c'est difficile de lui
c'est parce que ma fille est passé chez
il faut le vif
c'est comme le vivent tous les sept ans
qu'on a pensé moi je voulais que
l'information qu'on avait de tout ce que
le qu'est ce qu'on a vécu que d'autres
parents apprennent qu est ce qui se
passe comme la famille badia
d'autres parents qui ont perdu un enfant
ont accepté de témoigner et de
participer à nos enquêtes
julie tout aussi comme pascal yeux des
parents endeuillés qui t'ont aidé dans
son enquête oui parce que souvent
marmots les gens avec qui on est en
contact on veut redonner un sens au
drame qu'ils vivent et c'est exactement
ce qui est arrivé à jean shepherd la
part d'un adolescent de 15 ans qui morts
après avoir consommé du red bull
il ya décidé de nous accompagner à
toronto avec tout son courage
rencontré au red bull pour raconter
l'histoire de son fils au fabricant du
produit
énumérer mode quand on voit des gens
courageux comme ça on sent comme
journaliste investi d'une mission celle
d'aller le plus loin possible pour
trouver des réponses à leurs questions
qui deviennent finalement nos questions
et celle du public
sylvie trois tenues dans une source dans
lac mégantic qui est vraiment une
citoyenne qui s'est levé devant les
justices à une dame incroyable une
spécialiste en produits financiers au
colorado qui s'est rendu compte que dans
les cabinets d'avocats qui gravitaient
autour des victimes il y en avait un qui
était vraiment louche qui empochait
beaucoup d'argent alors elle ne voulut
les alerter elle envoyait tout petit
courriel comme une bouteille à la mer et
c'est grâce à elle qu'on a pu remonter
la piste du chasseur d'ambulances de
lac-mégantic morissette mais il m'a dit
tu sais mais c'est comme ça que je fais
mon argent manille est au sol c'était
tellement flagrant et d'une telle à
visiter j'étais dégoûté
certaines de nos sources sont même
prêtes à infiltrer un milieu pour nous
aider comme se faire embaucher au berger
blanc un refuge pour animaux
l'éjection est plutôt donné à froid et
un peu n'importe comment
contrairement à ce qu'affirme le
propriétaire du berger blanc ce qui a
donné des images dérangeantes qu'on
aurait pu obtenir autrement qu en caméra
cachée plusieurs personnes nous marque
comme journaliste comme françois beaudry
qui était l'un des premiers témoins à
parler à visage découvert en 2009 sur la
collusion dans les travaux routiers
nous sommes allés le revoir pour savoir
ce qui l'a amené à accepter de parler au
grand jour tu m'avais demandé si devant
mon refus de premier refus de témoigner
directement la caméra du monde y est ce
que tu serais prêt à le faire à visage
caché
la première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit à ce moment là j'étais
nouvellement grand père
oui je me disais est ce que je veux
vraiment que
mes petits enfants évoluent dans un
république de bananes de se voir avec
une cagoule sur la tête ça a été
l'élément chape qui a fait que oui je
j'acceptais je n'accepterai pas une
chose semblable dufour je parle du jouet
a pas roulé plusieurs années plus tard
il a reçu une médaille du courage de
l'assemblée nationale
et parlant de courage moment montré une
seule l'intégration m'a dit mais c'est
surtout le descendu ses pantalons puis
[Musique]
je sois plus josé comment tu as fait
pour recueillir des des complices aussi
ici mais je dois avouer que c'est une
surprise parce qu'on était là pour
parler de la disparition d'une femme et
ces femmes là autour de la table étaient
toutes des amis de cette femme disparue
un moment donné je leur ai parlé de
choses que j'avais entendu de rumeurs de
comportement inapproprié et ses fermes
là soudainement elles se sont ouvertes
et se sont mises à parler pour la
première fois ce reportage comme
plusieurs autres diffusé au cours de nos
300 émissions d' enquête a fait bouger
les choses notamment en menant à une
importante commission d' enquête
son printemps dernier cynthia gagner ne
se doutait pas de nom de choc que notre
reportage à les provoquer elle venait
tout juste de fonder un groupe de
soutien sur facebook
enfin quelques jours j'ai été bombardé
de 400 messages en attente personnel
j'ai eu des téléphones à la maison que
des gens qui cherchait de l'aide va de
même
ça a changé la vie de cindy 7 passes a
encore tout à fait on a fait un
reportage sur elle parce qu'elle voulait
se faire retirer une bandelette convives
installés pour un problème
d'incontinence
et elle travaille depuis ce temps là
pratiquement temps plein sur le sujet
gère un groupe de support de 750 femmes
il travaille avec le ministère de la
santé et avec le collège des médecins
d'en but comprennent mieux en charge des
complications liées à ces bandelettes
des sujets médicaux qui ont une portée
scientifique on a besoin des victimes
c'est des gens à qui ça arrive mais des
experts aussi dans le code du manganèse
ont cherché à comprendre comment ça se
fait que quatre enfants d'une même
famille ont tous des problèmes
d'apprentissage sévère les parents
soupçonnait la présence de manganèse
dans l'eau de leurs puits alors on avait
vraiment besoin d'experts pour faire
avancer cette enquête là ce cd je
considère et élever la petite ligne
missiles et puis même gentil sont la
croix famille
à peu près tous les membres de la
famille au déconcentration comme on dit
of reach out
[Musique]
avant de se quitter et je tiens à
remercier toutes ces personnes qui ont
produit avec coeur c'est 300 épisodes d'
enquête et revenez nous pour 300 autres
épisodes pourquoi pas à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
je